alright ladies and gentlemen we have one
special edition of a fireman kid while
Brian is in New York City taking care of
his friend they did a foundation charity
stand-up event last night at Gotham
comedy club would Dov Davidoff and their
boy Jimmy the Prince of New York I guess
they raised a ton of money but no amount
of money in the world can stop brain
cancer so shout out to them I'm glad
everyone came through and Brian sir is a
great time for thanks for everyone who
came out but that means Brian Cowen is
not back in LA so again I sent out my
bat signal and the man the myth the
legend the brains behind on it Aubrey
Marcus is here what's up brother what's
up man not too much man good to see ya
hell yeah what's going on good to take a
break from the writing man that's a
beast yeah cuz you you always come out
here when you're writing books how many
books have you written well I wrote one
book and then I turn it to an online
course because it's suck to the book
because I know you try to put everything
you ever know like this is everything I
know and one and people are like people
can't follow this isn't like flyzone too
much a lot going on so you know took the
lessons from that put it into a course
where I could kind of guide people
through that program you know that was
the go for your win and that's cool and
it really works with the course but not
as a book so failed book but this next
book is a legit book and I got some help
and it's getting published by Harper and
I got a real deadline and it's a [ __ ]
man is uh it's obviously a learning
curve like going through writing a book
when you first got done with writing
this first one realize like hats betters
online course yeah was it a relief when
you're done with it cuz like you know
we've got Jud app down here and people
talk about these projects or you know I
Stockton rolling about this with his
stand-up like he's putting together the
next hour which I'll shoot for you know
Netflix or whoever he signs with and
once you're done with that you're it's
like damn now what man there's almost a
depression yeah and the thing is for me
it's it's going to be a huge relief
though because I have on it running
concurrently you know like like what
you're saying is very much like an NHL
player wins a Stanley Cup or even a
Super Bowl player like after the
playoffs are like Oh
[ __ ] what do I do now I know but how I
got on it running like the whole time
through and this is just like extra
stress just like piled on top of it so I
feel like you know I've been used to
running hills and now I'm running hills
with a giant backpack with a bag on it
yeah what would cause hot like this day
and age it like there's honorable
there's New York Times bestseller
would be a success when you write them
you know I'm saying like I've had people
come to me go oh let's write a book
let's do this and I'm like how did they
track these like off you want to be on
the New York Times bestselling with I
would love that yeah but is does that
mean like it was a success there's so
many ways to cut it you know like that's
definitely one standard in one measure
of it but I think for me I'll know L
know if this book is the potential that
it possibly could be and that's really I
think the only thing you can judge
yourself on no matter what the [ __ ] you
do right like if you're waiting for
external criteria something else could
happen a bunch of other books could come
out or some of the tracking of the bad
people who've had the tracking of the
book sales get screwed up and so they
didn't make the list so if you put the
success on something external you're
likely to be disappointed and I think
for me reminding myself like my only
responsibility is to make sure this
[ __ ] thing is as good as I can make
it and if I can turn that thing in and
say this is the best book that I could
possibly produce I'm good man yeah this
is all you're like this is all I got
this is my dad for his that I bled on
these pages like this is all I got and
you're not a guy who like hires a
ghostwriter something like that like
writing with you just yeah I got an
editor who's helping me out and like
helping with the structure and stuff
which is super helpful because I was
like blue that the first time cause you
didn't use one the first time no didn't
use one the first no just like a [ __ ]
I got like a journal journal put up
chapters in it and just post it yeah so
he sure takes it my mother on the back
thank you you're welcome
where did he what is it um yeah so he's
definitely helping out you helped out on
a lot of different big books so it helps
with the structure but nobody can write
like if he tries to write a section and
I read it it's like I didn't write
that's not me it's not my book so I have
to go in and even rewrite anything
then he tries to put out there like this
section would be good I'm like yeah that
was good for you writing it that way but
it doesn't sound like me yeah like I
have a there's a cadence of how I speak
and there's a cadence of how I write and
it just feels odd if I'm reading
something that's supposed to be me that
isn't me you want to be organic like
Tony Hughes cliff and I were talking
about this yesterday like he shot his
special and he really was the director
producer I'll see the talent he wrote
the whole goddamn thing he did it in one
take which is rare so you know usually
does that it's stuff like that he said
like you can see the camera in like
tripping at one point and he leaves all
that in he's like because I want it
wrong really because I don't want to
hire a team he goes because thing about
you go through you have all this
material been working on the road for
years fine and shoot this one hour and
then going oh hey here you go
shoot it how you write it's gonna you
want to learn right same with your book
you have all these ideas you want to get
this thing out and go
cool man now here's my ideas now you do
it it doesn't make sense to me
like whenever I hear Sony goes oh I made
New York Times best selling looks like
cool did you write it though like well I
had some it was forward by get the [ __ ]
out of my face that guy wrote it use
your popularity get out of my face yeah
doesn't work for me yeah I think I also
think of myself as a writer too and I
think for some people if they're not a
write-up they're an athlete or something
like yeah I can't write so I got to get
somebody right but I I can write so I
have to do it it's like part of notes I
have no excuse it has to be me you know
there's really no other way and there's
even been times where I've been hoping
honestly if I'm being honest like man I
hope you can just take care of this
start I hope you can take it can it has
to be me every time I even every time I
try to get them up universes like now
[ __ ] you like you're gonna do this
and for good reason like well it should
be hard to write a book like everyone be
writing [ __ ] books yeah my 16th both
just some [ __ ] if you're nosy it's a
monster man it is and it's like it's not
just a book it's anything that you're
doing that's stretching you that's like
putting you out there so that people can
criticize you people can look at what
you've accomplished and and give you
[ __ ] or whatever like any time you do
that you're going to find resistance and
we all have that I think that's the
thing that prevents people in writing is
just a really tangible example of that
because it's a it's such a long process
and stuff
so slow like you get no gratification on
writing a book for years and I think
that's what makes it particularly tough
but everybody has those things that they
got it that they could do and should do
but they just feel that I don't know if
I want to do this when that's usually
where like haters come from yeah because
they see someone in this Lane or they
see someone trying this stuff and they
would never do it or maybe they want to
do it but they would never attempt
because they're scared so then they have
resentment in themselves and they lash
out at those people yeah you see it all
the time yeah they're mad at themselves
for not doing it so anybody else who
does how it triggers them that I should
be doing that but let's let me stop them
from doing it I'll justify the fact that
I haven't done some hateful [ __ ] out
yeah come on man it's use your private
account that's the thing if you have a
private count you're blocking my mind
that's my new thing a private count you
have no voice you just go into the
either and I block you yeah yeah it's
kind of like the cowardly way to do it
that's the sucker punch of online hate
yeah it's like if you're gonna do it man
up put yourself out there square yeah
but other people talk [ __ ] yeah man you
know and they it's a private counseling
they get no feedback you know because
they don't there's such policies after
you're gonna sort out they don't want it
back oh my god I won't even know to eat
if they put ah like don't hate on so my
other friends like I thought 20
Hinchcliffe suck do not click private
account block I do like Chris D'Elia
special blocked private account cash
cake it's actually a nice thing what's
up with fighters who I see this trend
now where there will like someone will
talk [ __ ] to them and then they just
post their address have you seen people
doing that to fight also yeah I've seen
like Cody do that I've seen Donald is
like Heidi yeah like here's my address
I'll be a BMF ranch if you want to come
[ __ ] and I'm like no don't do that I
didn't like that idea
terrible idea that's just hey man it's
not 1997 anymore I can't be doing that
for me I don't for 1 million reason
different listings I can't for sure is I
mean Cody my [ __ ] homeboy I love Cody
man and he's a 135 pound champ like just
don't put your address man you can't so
let's not fight regular guy
I saw something today some slaves in my
DM Sunday like did you see this
it's like bro actually shows up to
Cody's house or gym that was the thing
did one of our current events well no
because I didn't know if you guys wanted
to expose that can you bring it up
expose the guy so not that guy because
she's a pig jumping on my engine he
wants attention so like what did you see
the guy like white oh to even address
the student it's a bro with this like T
top clearly on steroids flesh and hat to
the side like some [ __ ] little
rascals character it's just I can't
believe Cody even entertained it I guess
all the patient Cody you're giving this
bro bro
some [ __ ] shine there it is Cody
government responds oh no it's just part
of his soul and part of his character is
that country boy who just fought people
you know what I mean and I think it's
part of what makes him so [ __ ] good I
agree but it's but it like look at you
gotta like I gotta be able to turn that
off when that guy's Govan would say it
said he couldn't get out of there quick
enough wasn't but ability shows up the
fight UFC champion hilarity ensues so
what's that say um where does MMA be
since they might agreed to box Syria he
went to his gym and he was like
videotaping himself on his phone it's
like oh I'm here bro I'm here were you
at and I guess Cody wasn't there for
obvious reasons like why I entertained
this so nothing happened nah they didn't
even see each other look at that guy
thank ya I mean a there was hottie he
would if this was like two years ago
some of the other goons at team al from
hell would a decision about it curl
stops I could he's not here but I'm here
[ __ ] I know Jaco Barrett yeah
I'm yours Oh bear that's exactly what it
happened yeah Cody's on here we are
taking the back and give me the
old-fashioned ass whippin
we're go ahead and beat that spray tan
off yeah which one pick your poison here
well we're all about 50 pounds lighter
than you but we will stay out you how
about Cody at whatever the [ __ ] his name
is I left my number two gym front desk
homey when you get to the gym what uh
that was a that dude Matt trying to get
you don't have to give that's why I made
a schwa so that's called Jesus how about
coda you almost kill people running out
of sat down down a one-way road road
fool [ __ ] you this ain't a joke to me
God Cody he has so much weight of this
guy he's just trying he's looking for
attention don't let him play on that
he's just dying for attention this is
the way they're doing it man TIA
did you see home for Cody for sure quit
doing that hand here's a UFC champion of
the world that you don't even entertain
this man he shouldn't even acknowledge
it because now what those weird trolls
who live in a mom's basement with
horrible cheeto fingers even though they
they came out the application where you
can you don't have to get cheese on your
fingers anyway I've seen that what some
Elon Musk of basements came out with
this new formula where you put these
this device on your fingers you don't
get cheese when he Cheetos so you like
Teflon your fig you like naughty thickly
and your finger some [ __ ] Bruce Wayne
[ __ ] grandma guy came up with amazing
but for Cody you're going to get those
guys now they know they can get a rise
out he so you're getting more of it more
of it yeah and just I get to sit down
with a lot of these fighters you do and
the thing that I always try to get to is
like what's the special sauce like why
are they attempt Ian how did they become
champion what mindset thing cuz
obviously they're great athletes yeah
there's something about them different
usually what they're always well some
like interesting facet about them that
made them so successful in with Cody
it's just it's an identity piece like he
identifies as a fighter he's like I've
always been a fighter I will always be a
fighter it doesn't matter it so when
he's in there he's so relaxed because
he's doing what he should do yeah you
know it's like this is the action this
is the only time where he gets to be
fully himself you know what I mean and
so I think it's hard you know both of us
could be like coach what are you doing
man but for him it's like no no this is
what I am yeah this dude calls me out
with my right hand I talk about like
this is what happened I know me now but
it you got to learn you got a real ended
no that's for the that's for the cage
and then this is for real life where
your
superstar celebrity you were on a Geico
commercial yes like when you're on a guy
guy guy guy goes [ __ ] huge I love
Cody and he should be on a keg kooler
shot however like the thing is with Cody
he's literally like that that he's like
he's a good-looking dude tattoos skills
he's that pitbull that you can't bring
around any other dog like he's the huge
liability because when you had a press
conference don't talk [ __ ] to him he
just [ __ ] from zero to a hundred like
you he'll try fighting dudes in the back
but the thing is he's so real about it
if you watch if you let's say about UFC
tonight atomic cruise like they were
like in separate rooms but dama Cruz was
like yeah you're gonna suck I mean uck
like would you say where yeah my golf
and you I tried getting doing like bro
we're just trying to hype the fight and
usually that would [ __ ] up someone's
mentality right like usually if they
come in mad like that they fight word
I'll bag going [ __ ] [ __ ] I know I would
toss oh no I feel the exact opposite did
you're so good I said let's start
hitting on them yeah talk about sex Cody
man you a sexy [ __ ] if you try
something different you throw a curve
ball don't piss him off bro you don't
throw this Trey heat no no you go you go
spit balls curve balls [ __ ] the the
Efus whatever you like whatever [ __ ]
Cruz did I would not do that
he told brakes off that boy and was
relaxed didn't show like crazy emotion
like he's one of the only fighters God
really one of the only fighters where
the [ __ ] talking doesn't get to yeah I
keep like he when he does it it makes
him so bad and he trained so much harder
beats the [ __ ] out of him I just like
I'm just gonna leave this one alone yeah
it's very very grand and he doesn't have
a lot of experience yeah like it he does
in life but as far as in the Octagon
for how good he is she doesn't have a
lot of experience to get there I usually
see that with vets with him on my
goddamn surprising them and I think it's
like he says it's his experience started
super young I mean fighting his older
brother every [ __ ] day
like stealing his Subway sandwich and
it'll turn into a knife fight yeah I was
like literally Subway sandwich to knife
fight yeah like that was that was the
escalation at the garb and household and
he's a good dude yeah that's the thing
like deep down sites a good dude but
when you say like his identity's
fighting I was out in New York and we
would like to speak easy I invited my
friend to speak using he just happen to
be with a bunch of fighters and he
fighters showed up and I was like you
know what the only thing you guys are
missing is a huge neon sign pointing
down going fighters here fighters here
fighters here because the way they were
dressed and one had flip-flops on and
they just you know they're basically
wearing affliction shirts and I'm like
fellas
is there any way you could look less
like fighters like that he's just what
then that's like that's what that we
identify with my god I try and go the
exact opposite where my tattoos [ __ ]
pin my ears back throughout my hair you
know I'm just That's not me and I try to
exact out I'm looking at these guys and
you know Brian was there I'm sure what I
wanted to roast some when he's back but
there's this guy they're called big baby
he's a k1 glory I'm sure wits worked
with him and he's enormous
they told me he's big and he was but
he's literally like 300 something pounds
big baby k1 striker fought cro cop but i
think recently lost nice guy nice guy
ever and he comes in and he has on like
you know it's cut off fleas camo pants
like might as well had boxing gloves on
his neck Brian just grabbed like there
could have been haha 17 swimsuit models
and Brian be live for him and everyone's
like what is your friends deal I'm like
I swear to God in that game when there's
a big guy in the room it's just what he
does and then so Brian has all them
around he's like showing them moves and
you know doing breakout and stuff and
brining his god man you I'm staring at
you and I'm like over there talking to
the [ __ ] business and their suits
Brian's over there with the fighters
real complete opposite I was I was
watching you I'm looking at these guy
I'm like you could not be any more off
than these guys he's you try to go the
exact opposite yeah like I was there man
I don't identify with that like I I get
and surround it you know well it's
probably where they're most comfortable
to and also it's that's their hook like
if you're going out in public and you
it's like you're fishing to a certain
degree for most men like you're fishing
to try and get some attention
you know chicks you're right and if the
only lure that they've fashioned
correctly is the fighter lure yeah like
that's the thing that they're putting
the bait on they got to let people know
it's true you know otherwise how they're
going to catch any fish I'm not going to
do it with they're witty they're witty
one-liners or they get elected their
deep conversations they're soulful games
you know like none of those tricks are
going to work although they look in
their tackle box they're like what do I
got a fighter
ok well decided to go that one yeah
let's go down like there was one guy
just this is one guy not your phase name
you guys know and he's in the bar and
he's that maybe one drink and he's just
he's steering like he's fighting his
next opponent like his like phone's
across but he's staring at a chick I
think his way is flirting he's just like
I came on like bro you you got ease up
on your imma looks good [ __ ] one mile
scare you got yeah it is just so intense
it's like real I'm like you're scaring
me I'm [ __ ] that you're scaring me
but you look like a rapist you guys
really yes just maybe a grill out evenly
you know what don't do the grin that's
creepy just I just keep doing - yeah for
everybody who's has like online dating
profiles like if you read any of the
psychology like the one thing you do not
want to do you can look at all the
studies do not have a picture where
you're folding your arms really light
because it sends off the sign that
you're closed off but you don't want any
interaction and the same as if you're in
the bar like the last thing you want to
do is put out an intimidating presence
like it's not the old caveman days where
you're going to get chicks because you
you know you're intimidating the [ __ ]
out of all the other men you're the
Alpha you're alpha men no like you
people will see that naturally but you
want to be as open and inviting the
conversation as you possibly can whether
that's an online profile or that's what
you're actually doing so never have your
hands crossed have you know don't have
like the goofiest smile but look like
look like it normally when normal guys
approachable yeah exactly
so why the buzz wife you know this [ __ ]
about online profiles
I was research
researchers put me on blast every
channel all right I've never been on any
of those things I've got a girl like you
reached out to me on ten I'm like not
intended oh yeah I saw her dating
catfish I saw a catfish in me too and he
was wittiest [ __ ] he's a beast he was
a beast on there he said he said oh hey
this was his line and he goes I'm not
really into bees but maybe you honey
Danse Macabre market will take you I'll
get you some I don't know how that works
then so you were doing research because
your book - how the hell does your book
like relate to online so we're going
we're going from like when you wake up
to when you sleep in the charting like
the ideal day so like morning routines
nutrition all the way through to like
workplace efficiency and then into the
evening is like when the best time to
have a glass of wine is and then a
chapter on sex and then a chapter on
like preparing for the next day
meditation journaling that and then
sleep but in the sex and relationship
chapter just going through all of these
different articles studies research on
sex and interpersonal communications
fascinating yeah you go deep and start
finding out these different cues and
just researching like Psychology Today
in these different blogs and sites that
does magic study because now two
different animal lights I mean even you
know we're similar age you're a little
older than me but you know growing up
and even you know even high school
college now it's different because how
was it 60 or 65 percent relationship
start online right yeah something like
rappers I'm really not younger I mean
older younger like a 18 to 36 I assume I
was reading a study I'm sure you wrote
the book so you would know but that's 60
or 65 percent relationship starlight and
but there's like this weird kind of
almost taboo like I would I would meet
someone go how'd you guys meet and like
actually when it's 10 and I go yeah for
real I don't there's the one where
everybody's I would stop I do I'd go
because I know I don't online that you
gotta go I don't get why people are so
scared to admit this how's that dinner
some friends they've been made for four
years I'm like go how'd you guys meet
and he's all should we tell him I'm like
oh [ __ ] pry some weird King
do you like sex group or some [ __ ] yeah
there's like all sex as a date Amahl why
are you guys embarrassed by that I don't
get it like people so embarrassed by it
I think there was a stigma back a long
time ago that you were desperate if
you're on that especially if you're a
girl like if you if you were like on and
on line you must be all you're desperate
and that's such it's gone like that's
old for good and then there's also
another stigma that if you're on tinder
you're just on there to [ __ ] and that
might be accurate to a certain degree
but I think those are the stigmas that
people are dealing with but you just got
to toss that out it's we live in a
different time in a different world now
you know and that's just part of life
this is a way that we communicate we
look how we can actually communicate we
communicate with each other through
texts and through we don't call people
like so of course the dating in the
courtship and the mating rituals
surrounding that it's going to be the
same as well it's going to have digital
format I mean that's just a part of our
communication period in people say all
romance isn't there anymore my god it's
taking out blame on technology don't
blame them on the guys it's not all the
guys you know like you he's living your
dm's you guys met through that like how
do you how do you think this thing's
gonna go down you know yeah and any for
anybody I mean everybody's on and online
datings happened it's called [ __ ]
Instagram I mean like this that's like
the og of I agree I mean I think it
beats tinder find all that [ __ ] it's
gonna be signed a DM it's literally like
what's up it's your axis they have a
profile and it's a real it's you can't
get catfished very easily because it's
you it's you have so much social proof
that it's the real you
yeah I've watched enough [ __ ] leave
on catfish where I can figure it out you
know I'm saying alright I did can
definitely figure it out I got it I got
someone slid into my DM and it was some
kind of transgender situation but it
looked like okay you remember there's
like if you went back to the old
carnivals there's these little slippery
sleeves that you had that were like hard
to keep in your hand and you'd like grab
another like same word out of your hand
does okay so she it heard there's it
Zinser whatever I don't know what I'm
supposed rolled out and she wants yeah
whatever pronoun Z once yes had like one
of those it was like a big one of those
she was doggy style had a big
and it was I don't know what genitalia
was like I have no idea what genitalia
was I don't have video games into the DI
was that singing like that thing and
some cancellations I don't know man to
this day like it haunts me dude I had a
doctor I had the same thing I had a one
girls in my Dean's and I read it like
gorgeous gorgeous and you know and then
found out she was a transsexual I had no
idea yeah I mean it's just it's part of
the game throwing it out there it's not
me catfish is just
no she wasn't get this hey bro God yeah
I said I was like man not my thing I'm
having a boy yeah I hope it works out
not my thing though you know I could
have slid in that weird pouch thing oh
yeah I get I want I don't know what you
milk it like another oh man I don't know
what I couldn't you you you have loved
the most in cheering lives like my
manager was in Miami is one of his
clients and he heard uh he was worked
out of something
and wit heard him talking about me to
another agency yeah like that so you
guys right next to each other yeah cuz
he was in there with Zac Efron yes
and then Zach left and then he started
got on a call talking about you
yes and so wit heard it and then I think
you text me yeah and then I told my
manager like you need to go over and
[ __ ] meet this dude and in he types
he's like dude he's like a young Hugh
Hefner my desk yes that of supplement
world and he's like a [ __ ] that's
exactly what he is man like this is
dudes needed no for me like you live
such a crazy life like last night let's
just this is already Marcus last night
yesterday me and I already had a nice
fine work out what Jesus after them who
knows I some fun weird [ __ ] someone had
a great meal went to dinner it's awfully
drug Butler
yep that's alright randomly Frank Butler
slides into your DM yeah
with a [ __ ] 300 mean yeah yeah he
goes because a it's Jerry Butler you
know the 300 guy did he know he did
pretty good
the Ohio
no you are i watch a movie 25 times when
I'm feeling sorry for myself and I'm
lying in bed and I want to [ __ ] stop
being a [ __ ] I turn on your movie like
I get it I know you are he's a haul and
just so you know it's mean to him just
no makeup going this is sparta no bro
you don't have to keep it yeah yeah you
have a blue checkmark next your names I
got a look at this yeah so he just
reached out was like let's grab a cup of
coffee yeah you know he got onto one of
my podcasts and it just really resonated
with some of the stuff that he was
interested in and something like the
spiritual consciousness concepts he just
hit the right podcast for him at the
right time and yeah and listened to that
and then started listening some more and
just this slitted my DM that was weird
because I was taking a [ __ ] just kind of
scrolling through looking for honey's
didn't see any honey I never see any
honey's on there just [ __ ] [ __ ]
and Gerard Butler like that's the mans
with balloons that other actually that
I've had a weird pouch balloons and in
spider seen you sponges over ice creams
you jock now I'm doing so good that is
not a good resource for me I leave had
to the tip rattles water man yeah but
yeah man it was really surreal is that
movie like a of all significant movies I
think like Braveheart Avatar 300 there's
like a couple that like made a
difference agree like an impact and that
was one well we did cool he's a cool
dude ranging wladim yeah I heard he's
like a guy's guy yeah his accent is and
he wasn't he wasn't trying to be more
than he was like he's kind of
self-effacing and funny and like you
know doesn't try to pretend that he's
super awesome or anything yeah show off
he's just he's real which was though and
and for you the connection was him a lot
of people like I'll be working out or
I'll be on the street and you know
people because your podcast has blown up
in so many you have like this this
following where people you know I think
they're inspired but and then they also
want to get into that DMT ayahuasca kind
of type of stuff and for Butler is it
more of that world kind of yeah I think
it's this this house for too long those
two worlds have been separate there's
like kind of like the the hippy
spiritual where's a crystal everywhere
they go
of talking about plant medicine group
right and then there's the you know
fight fan athlete you know kind of bro
side of things and both of those have
been two different worlds and I think
where I live is the space where I can
flow between both you know I'm not going
to wear the crystals but I'm going to go
as deep as anybody on that side with the
psychedelics and the philosophy and the
spirituality and then on the other side
you know it's I can relate to everybody
on that angle so I think for someone who
really is interested in exploring both
sides
I think they you know kind of appreciate
where I'm coming from because I can
relate to both sides yeah like
pigeon-holed in one the other they don't
get labeled labeled as that right have
you seen that for you to name the show
on Vice called I think some topia it's
about it so I think Hamilton ah yeah
Hamilton come yeah gee it's a drug show
on Vice but basically I'd be perfect for
this man form a copious I like that but
yeah I mean it it's kind of like this
dude I haven't watched the show I
actually met Hamilton at the psychedelic
science conference so we need a
conference or psychedelic yeah is it
cool is it where's fun and it's really
it's really exciting
like no hot chicks at the know well no
there's a couple like super hot
conscious feathers in the hair a lot of
flash tattoos on the favorite I put
program yeah yeah Hilton's uh
pharmacopoeia but man it's really
exciting because they have two different
psychedelics or what one's not
classically psychedelic but MDMA and
psilocybin both just completed phase two
clinical trials and the results of what
they're showing improvement for just
stunning how so I mean so on the MDMA
side the they're really focused on PTSD
and the the standard of care for PTSD is
really dropping the dropping the
incidence and symptoms of PTSD hardly at
all so it gets scored on a scale of like
0 to 100 and traditional you know if
it's the trauma scores at 55 traditional
methods will drop it to like 50 and it's
like a cocktail of 10 pills right and
all the pills have side effects and it's
just gnarly Thanks and then the
mdma-assisted psychotherapy where they
take MDMA it opens up their you know
opens up their ability to look at these
dramatic events process them with a
therapist and they're showing that after
three sessions they're not only treating
it they're curing it and then left and
then this so the scores drop down to
below where PTSD is rated and then
following up even further it it
continues to go down they don't even
need to continue taking it so it's not
like a normal drug model where you're
taking this pill all the time like a
year after all of the sessions are done
the trauma stores continue to drop and
there's legit reasons AIDS to clinical
trials multi-site placebo-controlled
randomized clinical trials are going
into phase 3 which is the final step for
approval so like this is this one thing
I think when I look at the things that
are going to change the world like
there's so many people with PTSD right
now and to have this come in and
potentially be able to treat it and cure
it not just treat it cure it it's
[ __ ] super exciting but the to play
devil's out get the big thing there and
get in that pass it would be getting out
these huge pharmaceutical companies who
are given those pills and all that stuff
who have the ties in to the doctors who
are tied into the therapists stuff like
that to get them to pass on that because
they don't make money off that right no
but you know it's too late because once
the scientific process starts you can't
really stop that train right like the
phase 1 trials justify the phase 2
trials the phase 2 trials justify the
phase 3 trials and then the statistics
speak for themselves like that's the
beauty of the scientific process is once
you go that angle it's no longer a
philosophical decision variable it's
undeniable and I think they're on the
way to proving that path I mean already
the patient population is super high and
they may even get fast-track status
which is going to speed the process even
more because it's so promising is it
expensive how's it going here to the
other stuff super cheap you know I mean
like to find super dope what does it
have anything about in science right and
it also can't be patented right this is
an old compound MDMA is an old compound
so there's no patent protects so they
can't drive the price up it's really
just and it's also a non-profit that's
providing it so Maps is going to come to
market as a non-profit and be providing
this so there's no long-term financial
incentive period this isn't another drug
company developing it
it's legit like a world changer and it's
maps org for anybody who's interested
and it's it's gonna [ __ ] change the
game and that's all the ones I telling
this [ __ ] no [ __ ] right I mean it's like
it's it's going to be it's going to be
really a true game changer if you think
it could help with CT and blade drama
and not that one but I would look into
on the other side the psilocybin trials
so there's two different organizations
the other organizations hefter and you
sona after after institute and they just
finished phase two trials and treating
like major depression and end-of-life
care and again this is one of those
things like depression is a beast to
treat traditional it's a beast
sometimes the pills help sometimes they
don't sometimes you give to people I've
friends and colleagues on you who have
stuff from horrible depression and they
give those pills and it's not them they
are in life in basically neutral like up
they never get happy then they get sad
then ever you excited they don't feel
life but they give them these pills and
then here's here's other solutions
coming in and this the psilocybin which
is the active ingredient in magic
mushrooms through randomized controlled
phase two clinical trials I mean this is
not this is no longer a theory there's
not just your home and you said oh yeah
man I took it I started feeling better
like we have the data now that's showing
that it's curing depression not treating
depression curing depression in a lot of
cases so the things are out there and I
think it's the combination of not just
the it's not just the substance it's
with the so it's psilocybin with the the
counseling that they provide but in the
placebo control is the count all the
same counseling but without the
psilocybin yeah and it just doesn't work
that well where's a little bittle you
have to have both because that allows
these trained practitioners to actually
get in it like opens the gates of the
mind and allows someone to actually get
in where they can start helping you
process and fix it is we're amazing
machines man we can self fix ourselves
yes but sometimes we just need a little
bit of help we build up these like
calcifications and armor if you think of
your brain like these memories when you
have a trauma same with like a body
trauma you know you're going to build
armor around it calluses that are hard
to penetrate and hard to pierce through
and these things just melt the calluses
away and allow you to get back into the
source of that infection the sort
the trauma the source of the depression
and start to fix it and there's other
mechanisms of action too but it's really
interesting to see what these two
parallel different drugs are going to do
to the world in in four or five years I
think when I look out and the
interchange the world the most and
people are sleeping on it man people are
[ __ ] sleep asleep well how many other
questions so there's a few kinds of
things that come to mind one would be
how many therapists are out there how
many no I'm saying to help guide these
people through this because if you need
both therapy yeah and the drug that's a
good question how many people actually
qualified to do it too it's always gonna
be about education same thing but you
know marijuana is kind of not over the
hump but with them compassion when
Denver look at the tax of the Dune there
and the economy in Denver legal Los
Angeles remember we'd had that culture
where it's like uh it's lazy guy yeah
it's guys who are losers they live in
mom's basement and no it's best not true
there's actually some benefits to
marijuana yeah obviously this is even
more beneficial but it's about education
educating the culture around it yeah and
I think that the thing that marijuana
hasn't had is this clinical trial it's
actually still harder to do trials on
marijuana than it is to do on MDMA and
psilocybin you know because marijuana is
like particularly a controlled substance
either keeping tight so you don't see
these massive phase true
phase two like statistical powers and
get the generate there's only been a few
little studies and that's I think where
a different track is going to go
marijuana is already on its own track
and that's you know you have big data
from what's happening in states like
Colorado and happening in states like
Oregon where every statistic is
improving except for like a couple
random ones I actually read one study
the only like negative study I saw on
marijuana is binge college drinkers have
now become binge marijuana smokers safer
yeah so like I guess you're pounding
like [ __ ] a case of beer maybe we're
gonna do whatever though yeah they're
going to do air weed or whatever but
other than that like all of the
different things are improving so that's
on that track and I think that's going
to be super helpful especially for pain
you know like I think marijuana
ultimately when
what how that's going to change the
world when they start to unlock the
ability to get like sanction marijuana
to use for trials which is still a [ __ ]
still a pain in the ass to get I think
that one has to go after pain because so
many people are dying from opiates and
addicted to opiates like if you could do
some targeted pain trials with marijuana
and show that that's a viable option
instead of all of these you know vicodin
and percocet sand all of the [ __ ] that
people are taking oxys then that's going
to change the world in that side so you
got marijuana coming for pain
you got psilocybin coming for depression
you got MDMA coming for PTSD and in the
middle there's these little things like
OCD conditions like anorexia and bulimia
there's good evidence that maybe
psilocybin could be helpful for that and
like little different targets you know
along the way and then all of a sudden
all of these things that are just
plagues of our world plagues of our
society we start to have viable options
so we don't feel [ __ ] helpless
yeah anymore because that's the worst
part it's like right now nothing works
that good so you're just kind of
helpless you got a bad solution and a
bad problem well then when you say a bad
problem it's a lot of time you know
these these random shooters these people
do these terrorist acts a lot of them
suffer from mental illness mm-hmm a lot
of it comes from horrible depression
they never fit in anywhere they don't
relate to any group so y'all I can
relate to Isis for whatever [ __ ]
reason - really - that if they're this
random shoot in America you know yeah
yeah and I think and then the other
thing too is if you're feeling this bad
you know you're way less likely to be
kind to your community like we're
talking about haters at the start of the
show like that comes from internal pain
that comes from internal suffering and
as these things start we start to be
able to actually affect these and treat
these and cure these things people are
going to be nicer to other people then
those people are going to be nicer to
other people and then maybe these people
that once felt isolated as people
release their own pain maybe more people
take the ambition to reach out and be
like hey man how you doing yeah you do
know I like everything good with it on
you know and and that kind of connection
because we're tribal social creatures
and without that when we feel isolated
we're going to go crazy and do crazy
things so I think the ripple effects of
all of this I really truly believe that
yeah this may be a little
bit of a tricky stretch that were in now
about five years the combination of
these treatments that are coming out and
just the consciousness it's raising I'm
[ __ ] wicked optimistic that SIL
psilocybin yeah I said yeah where does
it come from
mushrooms psilocybin so like magic
mushrooms how the [ __ ] do we get a
psilocybin factory yeah I know right
it's I mean if you thought about any of
that yeah I mean ultimately ultimately
I'm just waiting on these trials to come
through and then seeing where I mean
this is such a big thing the the
monetary side of it is like it's such a
secondary concern to the you know like
the marijuana I think is a good business
as far as like if we're liberated
business but as far as these things it's
almost like it better if nobody makes
money on it like these are just like
things that should never get a workshop
either rights should be like rights of
like the world of rights of the world in
nature yeah I want to be an agent me
like maybe like I'm not like a big
universal health care guy I don't know
where I stand I truly like the free
market but I think some things that are
this significantly like this
significantly powerful to change lives
in such a short term be free like we
should have even if the government
doesn't do it like organizations charity
organizations like maps that run it that
are truly doing this from a non-profit
project a realistic dough um I think it
I think it is man I think we're
charitable people and I think it's just
when I mean look how much money we're
giving to you know to feed different
nations and we're funneling massive
amounts of money that's not really being
used all that effectively yeah you know
and even if you look at the stats of
something like you know red Red Cross
right like Red Cross a lot of times is
only getting thirty percent of what it
raises on to the ground actually helping
people because the organization is so
big right so and there's just millions
and millions and millions going through
that like if you could direct it and let
people know like alright look you can
either feed somebody who's you know
who's hungry that's really good but it
cost this much or you can change
somebody's life forever in three
sessions who has trauma or depression
like let's funnel a little bit of that
money over there
I think some of these people that are
just hoarding wealth when they can
actually see that man this is going to
do some really good like maybe I'm
hoping that some of that wealth just
starts pouring in from these places that
people are hiding it do you ever think
maybe you're that middle man
maybe yeah it's your journey for sure
man or sure cuz you're gonna have to
have sown that educates these
billionaires or the people that control
that funding right yeah yeah that can't
be a madman I can't have a guy in a lab
coat crazy [ __ ] in here tell me how this
is going to solve or someone who doesn't
understand business and I think that's
where it'll be helpful to like look man
I understand business understand profits
and cash flow I understand psychology of
all this I understand the psychology of
wealth you know I like nice things I
have a super expensive watch on right
now that watch it on and like so it's
not like I'm not I don't see where
you're coming from you know I'm not
telling you that what money is bad I'm
the last person to say that but here's
where you can make a significant
life-altering difference and you may
have done some [ __ ] up [ __ ] you may
have taken advantage of people but
here's a chance to slug and switch the
karmic tables and do something else if
you look at someone like Bernie Sanders
and his ideas we're going to tax all the
money from the rich [ __ ] you're not
going to tax the money from the rich
they're too clever so they're going to
hide it here and there and in this
different country and you can't even tax
money that people already have you can
only tax the money that they're
currently making correct those [ __ ]
who have 80 billion dollars you're not
going to get any of that Bernie I just
think I'm dead Bernie you're going to
make them angrier by trying to take
their to have a lot of power a lot of
control yeah you got to get them to want
to give it yes
like you got to get people that's how
we're really going to get equality is
not by forcing people we're got to get
them to want to otherwise you know any
type any active aggression act of taking
is going to cause a defensive reaction
they're gonna be like ah you're going to
get it it's going to be over here in st.
Barts you know I'm gonna island yeah
[ __ ] off yep you know so I think that's
the I think that's really the key that's
what starts to to shift the the plate
tectonics of the world I feel like if
you get a board of directors together
like you're the lead guy and then you
got like Elon Musk you've got these
mantras like these these brainiacs who
have influence or like lumped-element
we all we want to do is make the world a
better place i'il I must talks about you
know he says that you know
some crazy [ __ ] like I think we have 20
years left on earth before we got to get
out of here you know he said some weird
[ __ ] but if you have a guy who's
constantly trying to make the world a
better place if you could have a guy
like that behind it as well you know
again the biggest obstacles in the
education education and then the data
the data is what we really need and then
they're publishing the all the data for
these phase 2 trials and when the phase
3 comes you know you just can't argue
with it that's the beauty of that's the
beauty of the scientific method it takes
these things out of out of the realm of
debate and into the realm of fact what
what negative side effects are there
have you guys found any hardly any man
as far as like the toxicity you know
there's virtually virtually no toxicity
actually with psilocybin we're finding
neurogenesis like new neurons are
getting actually regenerated in the
brain if it's actually shifting the
blood flow patterns around in the brain
and it seems to have massive like
massive benefits and the other side
effects of course are euphoria
forgiveness of your father who you hated
like the side effects are like positive
side effects and anything like that one
guy studies an orange start peeling skin
off no not in this setting because so
much of it yeah that happens with
mushrooms if you just do it in a weird
space and you're in a weird space you
got weird death metal playing and
there's a [ __ ] it's gonna get weird
it's gonna get weird I don't want like
if you go back to like mushrooms these
things are not they're just tools you
know they're not like good or bad but
when used the right way these tools are
incredibly powerful when used the wrong
way they're ghastly
like if you look back at the history of
Mexico in the Aztec King Moctezuma he
was taking mushrooms with his priests
the same thing that is healing all this
depression the same you know what looks
like could be a miracle drug he was
taking that and then carving the hearts
out of people pushing it through their
[ __ ] death God's mouth the war gods
mouth and kicking people down the side
of their pyramid by the thousand days
and night day and night fuelling
themselves off mushrooms like you can
use these tools for whatever the [ __ ]
you want but when used correctly they
can be amazingly beneficial Jesus Christ
all right that's such intense Montezuma
kazuma Jesus and
Kazuma so Matt Cortez and it was like
and Cortez was like burning people at
the stake the whole way like both both
Western and and those kind of
Mesoamerican people were involved in
some form of human sacrifice I mean they
were literally burning people at the
stake which is lighting people on fire
that were alive because they didn't have
the same religious beliefs as them so
that's is like [ __ ] crazy and then
the other people are carving prisoners
hearts out and pushing the hearts
through the mouths of a stone gosh so
dark dark and also so stupid so what the
state is so stupid yeah if you ghost or
listen this you guys are so stupid how
many times do you have to take that
psilocybin I think it's a three cycle
course again and how long does that take
not that long I think there's like a
month Oh sir lay out much of it I did it
now I have to wait 30 days dude yeah I
think 30 to 60 days to do it there's a
me sign it helps brain trauma I will
start it right now yeah I haven't seen
those I haven't seen those trout I know
CBD be the guinea PS CBD is showing some
promise yeah yeah rain trial I don't see
why I started doing a vape pen at night
in the CBD I know that I Cole all talena
use a broadcaster with whitney for glory
yeah Bazooka Joe CBD was literally the
only thing that can control his
splitting headaches from his concussions
that he got maecius and so he's on a
real high CBD protocol but he has to
take it before every broadcast as soon
as the lights and soon as everything
comes like the headaches will come ah
stop stop fighting army stop hey hey
Zuka Joe if you listen this and the ways
to the head if you have to take
medication cuz lights ruin your day yeah
like you get yes stop man yeah you have
to stop is there any scientific proof
that CBD actually helps with any of that
though again that the trials are the
trials are really lacking in Alba yeh ah
and CBD comical [ __ ] it's the access
because you have to have a controlled
standardized substance that you have to
like register and get from the
government for these and for some reason
the government's controlling the supply
of the controlling like the medical
marijuana supply like the standardised
supply why is because of the money
so yeah stuff like that tobacco and it's
like just old school thinking people
holding on to you know people holding on
to the field lay the old ways again
that's education education and in
flexibility of thinking is just I think
it's one of the great curses of our time
like you look at the diseases around
like the inability to change your mind
is a disease like I think we got to look
at that like that's a disease that's a
sick person yeah the only whole isn't if
you see all this evidence and you can't
change your mind and make you were wrong
you've got a you've got an ego disease
yeah you know and so you got a like so
much your identity like it's what's the
definition say doing the same thing over
no repetitive no looking for different
outcome yep the hell are you doing
insane yeah I'd be like if the girl with
the pouch kept sending me photos even
though it's over and over but over never
in pouches different fabrics is like I'm
gonna get OPA I'm a get away get away
you lazy they just needed to see mission
it uh I was the kid that doggy style
isn't gonna work he had some kind of
attention that is fascinating then I
would I would love it can you imagine
there was something for CT brain trauma
for football players fighters all these
athletes we say hey when you're done
playing you can take this and you meet
with this therapist and you're gonna be
fine
you know what the game changer that
would be and I think with no for
everything that I know my my good friend
a doctor I know doctor Daniel he just
wrote a draft of a book called the
concussion repair manual that I'm going
to give you an example of and there's
not one smoking gun there's not one
thing like it seems like psilocybin
might be able to knock out depression
and MDMA might be able to knock out PTSD
but the brain as an organ and as tissue
is really complicated and so it's the
combination of you know there's some
really good evidence that cat's claw
which is an amazonian herb is really
valuable and that CBD is really valuable
and then turmeric with curcumin is
really valuable like dropping all of
these inflammatory responses in the body
and then doing things like hyperbaric
oxygen is really important
like glutathione which is the master
antioxidant for the liver
you got to attack it from like ten
different perspectives it
as far as everything that we're seeing
now it's this really going to be this
multifaceted approach that's going to
start to bring things back but I think
we'll get there it's just going to have
to be more of a protocol rather than a
single a single treatment but again it
goes like the education it's a matter of
fact of finding you know just a matter
of time finding what works and try to
but being aggressive about it we got to
we got to because this is a I mean
there's a whole crop of human beings
that are having a lot of suffering
because of this and it's not just the
not just the top athletes these are
people let me people play Pop Warner
through high school yeah I go football
tournament tons of people and even even
they're finding like people are heading
soccer balls their whole life oh yeah
soccer it's a ton of content about brain
trauma and and do we want to have a
world where people don't play these
sports like no that's the thing I don't
want that world either so the solution
is find better ways to fix the brain
it's not putting a bigger [ __ ] helmet
or taking the helmets off or changing
the gloves so now that's actually
finding a way to cure the brain yep
take care of the brain I should say and
cure these things yeah and I think
what's scary
you know the UFC's you know when leather
helmet days right now in empathy stages
wait 10 years Leighton minha old UFC vet
your favorite guy in your you'll will
have a conversation like what in the
[ __ ] yeah what is going on here and
those are the that's the price you pay
man how in the again one MC stages wait
10 years man
there's give me some [ __ ] look
football's going through it now they got
the settles in court there's a huge
concussion case right the guys are
getting there's hundreds of millions
dollars in settlement you know wait wait
till you see men wait for mixed martial
arts it's coming it's coming together
it is hopefully I'm open to that
there'll be some adaptations and
training like maybe the utilization of
VR for to take off some of the sparring
low yeah some ways in which you can just
diminish that because the fights suck
but that's an acute like the body's good
at recovering from acute trauma like
something happens once a couple times
and the body recovers like by super good
at that what body sucks at
is recovering from chronic trauma you
know which is sparring day and day I'm
not on stantly getting hit and I think
if people can find ways because you need
the rounds you know you got to be able
to move and react find ways to blend
technology and the right and the people
who don't spar without headgear to like
you still see that like well III don't
see is good what I know what you don't
see is it's uncomfortable it's on what I
know like no put your headgear on binome
it but but finding ways to get smarter
about that that's I think that's going
to be really really key I think it's
going to take you know you see open up
that big kind of lab and that the whole
research center and I think so take some
creme de la creme dr. soand going this
is what you guys should be doing then
it's gonna take some champion going this
is what I did whether it's Conor
so unlike it Connor comes along because
here's what I did I took no damage in
training this is the protocol I did here
you go cuz there's kind of these
pioneers who changed the game GSP so far
is you're the face of it
he's our George Washington because he
was the first guy who really approached
it like a training camp you know where
he was doing different stuff you do
these eight we can't and he had
dietician he had a massage therapist he
male met with a mental coach you'd go to
yoga you do gymnastics he would do this
then he do boxing here the entry with
Olympic Center and he's like put in I've
never seen that for the first time like
oh my god here you go and that trickled
down so you need someone that comes
along because I might get him the head
during training anymore man this is what
I'm doing but then he's performing the
haka yep I don't know who's gonna be
able to come along
I can't Connors close you know Connors
close to doing that and he's not taking
a lot of [ __ ] head trauma
you know oh yeah I don't I don't know
what is the exact training looks like
you know I'm not sure um but but he
needs to publicly go out and do that but
you're probably not going to do that
until he's retired so yeah you know I
mean doesn't want to give up the secrets
yeah I don't know then but he needs me
right oh man this is what's going on
because in football you like a guy like
Jim Harbaugh or I think there's been
some other coaches who we goes wheel
hitting camp we won
once we end the season we don't hit
anymore these guys should know how to
hit why would I why would I put you know
risk their their head and these injuries
during training like to get to this
level you not to play football you not
attack each other so we do no contact
anymore
and when we heard that especially come
from my background like ride a bunch of
[ __ ] light it's like that ego kicks in
like oh my god it's lish and they start
winning games and then it's in season
the freshmen we are and then now other
teams oh well we're gonna try that too
and then again it started this thing
where now there's no two-a-days can't do
three two days in a row anymore you
can't do these crazy long prices you
can't can only hit this much can only do
it so it's just again this education and
the kind of the evolution of sport more
is not more you know that's this idea
that we have like more work will be
better work no you got to work
efficiently you got to work smart work
you know you got a more training is
better no it's not you know you got to
train and then recover efficiently like
in every aspect of what you do like
doing your best isn't doing the most
doing your best is finding that sweet
spot where you've done you know your
best work that allows you still to
recover and perform excellently than I
do an efficient work yeah it's the same
even with me writing a book like I can
write 16 hours but then the last six is
going to be [ __ ] you know and it's not
going to be good and I'm going to be
exhausted and I'm going to lose any
sense of humor that I had any kind of
enjoyment in it and it's just going to
get through it's going to feel like a
grind when people read it rather than if
I I if I just do a good six seven hours
a day and then call it a day yes and
then go on from there and anything that
you do like finding that sweet spot of
where the balance is because we can't
bear the stress forever we don't want to
be stressed out forever you're stressed
out forever
your immune system goes off your
inflammations I like stress response and
recovery stress response and recovery
like that's what we need to get to and
be mindful in MMA it's tough because you
know it's always like common out
training the guy I'm fighting up the
pressure the fight the nerves or the
fight and ready for a fist fight and for
millions of people so you have that
pressure
remember your coaches aren't your age
they're they're old school so they want
you to spawn you need to do this and
that's out worth the competition and
it's just
this old way of thinking so I'm thinking
you know as the game of Vols and the
fighters currently there now go God been
through that man I was always hurt
during the fight so it's not the way to
do it and they become coaches and their
training the younger generation you're
going to slowly start to phase out those
meatheads agreed yeah things happen
because again people don't change their
mind
that's the [ __ ] up thing it's like
people don't change their mind just like
I think you're right very few people can
do that those are like the 1 percenters
who can like totally pivot their
position that's awesome but otherwise it
just has to be new people replacing them
you know we see that government policy
you see that in coaches and you see like
just the new crop rises up my god we're
doing this [ __ ] different but you can
see it in in technology and anything
like people to rise to the top like will
you Steve Jobs yeah I think now I'm not
doing it like that our office shouldn't
be that way our stores shouldn't be that
way and then it changes yeah but you see
these people go in there now everyone
follows them yeah but for a while people
thought they were crazy
yeah those men let's go some colonel
mention there's a coal fire Sabri just a
couple questions yeah so uh ibogaine 93
united that's a question uh so I know
it's like for opiate addiction that's
what it's she's like used for mostly but
have you thought of trying to just oh I
went three times you've done it three
times it's hell it's like truly hell
like there's psychedelics that are hard
and then there's psychedelics that are
hell and that's held last 24 hours you
feel like you're in a high voltage we
what are we talking about I have a logo
I've not heard of the iboga yeah it says
without a from Gabon and they use it a
lot in the treatment of opioid today
it's really beneficial what it feels
like and I think one of the reasons why
it works so well is it feels like you're
an aunt and you're on a tuning fork and
then some [ __ ] land of the Giants
Giants grabs that tuning fork and goes
dying and you're just vibrating on this
medicine burger for 24 hours and a lot
of people are completely blacked out
like I was fortunate enough that I was
able to keep my thoughts and I had a
really valuable experience but you're
like buzzing like you're in a shed you
can't see you're like blind you're
vomiting it's incredibly painful like
you're trying to get relief by just
moving around a little bit
but you come out of that and you're
completely a different human being you
mean any god damn lot you claw
yeah like anything anything that any
addictive pattern you had
psychologically literally physically it
feels like you just went to ground zero
what's your goal dude oh my god out for
24 hours 24 addiction so for heroin
addiction I watched someone detox off
him he came in Hollow wide empty felt
like a soulless Joel coming just a shell
coming in like like this and then he
went through it he was up for three days
in a row because they gave him a way
bigger dose than me because I wasn't
addicted so I just had the spiritual
journey which was hell but his hell was
like three days like rolling around
sipping ice chips like and then but he
came out of that I saw him then he slept
for day for like slept all day day for I
saw him on day five and he just looked
at me and I was like I almost started
crying I was like holy [ __ ] like now a
human like a human with soul and
kindness and compassion is looking at me
what verse four it was like a [ __ ]
ghost and it was it was really a wild
experience we should just go down it
there's a center called crossroads in
Mexico which is far and away the best
center and for anybody who knows someone
who's struggling or is struggling
definitely look up that I have no ties
to crossroads but I know that they're
providing a really high standard of care
they're hooked up with a hospital down
there so intense it's so intense though
I don't have any dish I don't recommend
it to people who don't have something
serious going on even though it's
incredibly beneficial for me I don't
recommend it because it's it's gnarly
it's a little bit like Aldous Huxley he
said you know you don't want to burn the
house down to bake a loaf of bread like
if you're looking to improve a few
things like this is this is too clutch
just too much for you yeah Wow
oh one other question uh have you tried
you know much about kratom have you
tried it I have what are your thoughts
on it
yeah kratom is an interesting compound
be old on you probably longer yeah I
don't do any drugs okay I'll try create
them though it's illegal it's a legal
supplement here yeah what do I can kinda
kind of quasi like you're not supposed
to ingest it but it's
that owns so they have to say it's like
an incent it's a plant that comes from
Indonesia it grows in these little balls
that come from a tree and they actually
it's the active ingredient is what they
make tram it all out of you ever have
tramadol it's a painkiller yeah it's
like a non opiate painkiller I've had
that so really what it does yeah it's
not like it's strong that's like a
painkiller but it gives you this kind of
mild pain reduction slash euphoria type
of thing it can be pretty addictive -
yeah it has its own kind of addictive
pathway and kratom has that kind of same
thing it's a little bit of energy
sometimes it gets a little tired takes
away some of your pain it's cool but I
don't I don't like put it in like the
it's not something I talk about like
this is one of the great medicines you
know it's just kind of like this is a
little bit like a strange type of weed
or something you know if you take your
chin or what I've taken it before you
what do you like it for I do have back
pain and it looks a little bit without
right just a little bit not as much as
I'd like like chronic gosh it's like
it's like a 10 15 percent off the 10 50
percent off the top take an aspirin it's
it's not really it's like it's like
coffee but more relaxing yeah if that
makes a yeah I think that's fair yeah
coffee bit more relaxed I think you'll
probably dig it I you'd have to take a
lot - I feel like they've deep prescribe
it right no I'm just the tramadol they
prescribe a little I thickened kratom is
kratom is in this weird gray ER where
it's legal to own and possess but you're
not supposed to eat it because it's not
generally regarded as safe by the by the
government it's so instant a weird kind
of category partly because the active
ingredient is in tramadol but you can
get some pretty readily I think most
like smoke shops have it you can order
it online there's this type that I take
is called red vein borneo kratom and
it's it's good if if someone's listening
like I've never done a psychedelic of it
you know I want to try it they're a
little scared what would be kind of the
go-to you'd recommend yeah I mean I
would eat a little bit of weed
I would like where you believe yeah I
would go a short time yeah I go up to
like 10 milligrams and then get used to
feeling that and like practice breathing
practice letting some of those panic
kind of thoughts come into your mind and
then working your way back down from
them let's say they've done weed yeah
then I think psilocybin
would be the next escalation from there
or smote you eat that you eat it yeah
and you you always want it like no don't
go for the [ __ ] hero dose you know
like no you leave it into this like
exactly this isn't trying to show off oh
yeah I took five grams bro heroic dose
Terrance but kind of [ __ ] off don't do
that yeah not smart you're just opening
yourself up to way too much risk there's
a place for that but it's it's not in
that situation that's with someone who's
guiding you watching you like guiding
for some purpose to get you there so I
would you know out in nature gram gram
and a half I think can be an incredibly
beautiful experience going to refresh
your joy of living and what how much you
you can experience and how much you can
love life itself like I think that's a
good recalibration there and then
potentially step it up from there but
you know again only do these things if
you're really called to it but they can
be really powerful obviously we
benefited me greatly sillas yet no [ __ ]
I'm in I would eat it right now
psilocybin what is it illegal illegal
except in if in Amsterdam it's legal you
can get if Simon Lee you get psilocybin
truffles in Amsterdam and get those and
then Mexico it's largely decriminalized
Portugal it's decriminalized there's
some places where you can go where it's
not necessarily legal but not illegal so
it's a beast again the state's people
listeners yeah yeah dark web connection
yeah yeah and you want to be careful too
because you know the wrong mushroom is
just straight poison right like you got
it you got to watch out for what you're
doing and I don't that's why I don't
really recommend it all that much like I
recommend going the legal routes like if
you really called to it go do ayahuasca
in Peru with the right person or he'll
do peace bro that's a beast it's hard to
listen right now like what the [ __ ] I'm
just killing those poisonous a little
bit a little bit of weed in a flow tank
and meditation and yoga and you know a
lot of things you can do with breath
like start with the stuff that you can
do yeah unfortunately I wish there was a
world which all these options were
available and they were cheap and
nonprofits were supporting it like
that's the world we're building you know
we're not there yet so in the meantime
you know work with what you got and
there's so many ways up the mountain
it's like all of these have different
they're different paths but they're all
getting you the same spot they're
getting you out of your own head getting
you to like repattern some negative
programs in your body and you know this
is just a bunch of ways to do that you
don't need the plants are you at a point
now where like weed or like edibles
don't really do much but it's just fun
for you no I I still I still get [ __ ]
sometimes surprised and floored but like
I'll take you know I'll take some weed
thinking I'm gonna stretch and then all
of a sudden I'm looking back like whoa I
didn't see that I was totally blind to
this one aspect of the way that I was
thinking about this thing or this thing
that was bothering me it's interesting
like and weed does that for you we can
do that why not every time I go yeah I'm
like ah who the [ __ ] invented Coolridge
and why do I like that compared to the
cheddar one you know like that's my
process yeah and a lot of times I
remember a lot of times that's me to
just every once in a while you know
it'll take me to something that I
haven't seen and especially if I set the
intent for that like alright let's go
hunting for the shitty parts of my
psyche and the shitty parts of myself
that are making me sad and making me not
enjoy this amazing life that I have
enough let's go hunt for those shitty
parts and not out of anger spider
judgment but let's hump form cure so
that I can yes take a look at them and
fix them forgive them move on but when
you really need a fix [ __ ] you're not
just one can lead you not would I go to
the I go to the bigger plants for that
usually so that's you know ayahuasca if
I really need to move some some heavy
[ __ ] psilocybin is a great one and I'm
pretty comfortable with it bogel Astra
zort
you know if I really felt completely out
of whack that's level five that is like
your level five yeah totally there's
other great ones watch Huma there's so
many different plant medicines and
things that are available I mean [ __ ] me
I really feel like these plants were
here to help us out you know like hey I
want a beer
exactly and what house would they
interact with our body in such a
specific way like the receptors lining
up with like the tryptamine receptors
that we have available only getting
activated by the certain compound avatar
it's like the horse and with it and it's
like boom yeah and then of course DMT
too you know smoking DMT is short it's
sweet
it lasts like an hour and a half and you
know you go in
totally totally yourself and you come
out just a little bit wiser a little bit
better person to yourself and it's an
hour and a half but that counseling its
Worley - yeah you know actually you have
to be careful with all these things this
is not to be trifled with these aren't
toys yeah you know this is in some ways
always a trial by fire
it's fascinating [ __ ] great stuff any
other drug question [ __ ] Natalie I don't
know our producer the drugs legal stuff
but yeah never Holmwood alright so I'll
start off with the sad stuff first you
are on the show ridiculousness
you and Brian yeah so steelo brim was on
the show his three-year-old nephew
drowned in his pool and you know now
that summer this stuff happens quite
often it's [ __ ] terrible so you know
what I was listening to somebody talk
and they're like everybody freaks out if
you have a gun in the house right a gun
in the house and kids [ __ ] panic no
but swimming pools kill way more [ __ ]
kids and then guns but nobody pays
attention to that like it's just I will
pull up my house and it's like [ __ ]
Fort Knox getting that thing for my
little minutes
it's a literally I have a gate around it
like this it's a mesh gate like you'd
only be able to get through it and then
there's it's like cement in the ground
with poles and I open it up to go in
there and it's it's my biggest guy to be
honest I didn't want a house with a pool
because of that with kids something else
you got to worry about but wifey [ __ ]
like this it's like so the magnetosphere
man yeah and also kids can learn to swim
early too like another good thing it's
like you know safe things you do that
don't get them in the water super early
every Friday I have a this instructor
come the house and the first I thought
is enough to slap this [ __ ] the first
way they teach your kid is they kind of
put him face down just let they know and
they flip him over that it's gonna be
okay so if he were to fall in he kind of
you know he's 16 months man but you know
they don't sink to the bottom they teach
him it's kind of worst case scenario
first which I thought was a little weird
but she's been doing for like 25 years
her kid ease it down her knees she
she's in a onesie show Bush anyways
she's a beast of a trainer is what I'm
getting at and I was kind of alarmed at
first because she puts them in and then
to hold them flip them hold them it's
interesting stuff man but you need that
because if yet if you have a pool he
falls in you don't want to [ __ ]
drowning yeah just take all the measures
you can eliminate risk it's never be
able to nerf the whole world but just
start taking down risk where yeah I've
got him out you're not done to my house
now you're not getting out of my house I
gotta watch the hole yeah yeah I put I
put [ __ ] landmines in the yard I just
want my kids on [ __ ] just panic them
all the time they glare good human day
like american gladiator ninja warrior
are you hungry
good luck my man that's this course here
don't hit the landmine grilled cheese on
the other side you have little balls on
ropes that you're trying to throw idea
huh cheeky chicken the tennis ball John
yeah key key key trying to get to the
grilled cheese cheeky
that's [ __ ] terrible then shut up
steel rim another thing to remember I
played a video like on how many weeks
ago of a kid climbing into a dresser
drawer and then the dresser yes I want
to know that we played that video
literally a week later my friend his kid
had happened to him and luckily nothing
happened the the kid was safe he or she
she found a way to like wriggle out with
her ladies is crazy but that that's
another thing that happens all the time
to like people don't tie down their
their dresser drawers literally think to
do it kind of tough to do to but also
watch your [ __ ] kid yeah that's true
alright the next one another bad one a
girl and a boyfriend
we're trying to get more viewers on
their YouTube channel and get more
social media followers so they did a
stunt where the guy was holding a book
to his chest and she was going to shoot
a gun and then she ended up killing him
books are bulletproof all of sudden
exactly well just from the pigs okay
she's a 19 year old girl she's pregnant
she has a 3 year old daughter and yeah
accidentally killed her boyfriend did
she hit the book will hit the book but
it went right there obvious
listen to her before this went down
first of all is she's shining at YouTube
famous super thirsty for fame but her
tweet but me and Pedro are probably
going to shoot one of the most dangerous
videos ever his idea not mine
end quote yeah I mean how did they test
that and think like my year was a book
they saw someone do it before same book
same gun
how close there's so many music there's
so many factors that go into shooting to
it
was it a 22 did she get out a desert
eagle I went blank I took you and she
has [ __ ] Moby Dick there you know
it's like it's a bit there's a lot of X
factors here but also but also you're
not going to get famous off shooting
your boyfriend Pedro on YouTube through
a dictionary nope what friends what the
[ __ ] your mom do but the other thing she
shouldn't do that much prison time right
manslaughter
I guess right it's alternative them
maximum would be 10 years so when it's
not like she you know purposely murder
them should be route 3 yeah I want you
me [ __ ] what at least [ __ ] what a
nightmare though that's just gonna haunt
you forever ah yeah you point-blank shot
you over the chest
yeah do [ __ ] RL Stein [ __ ] paper
cover back you you're serving a prison
sentence anyway for being a [ __ ] you
know I'm saying oh god damn and she has
kids I live with dad ah [ __ ] your dad
want me to shoot him to this book and
why would you do that because one be
famous like George Clooney let them make
sense mom it's a [ __ ] terrible idea
it's just it's hard for him especially
it's just Fame for fame sake it's not
like they had a show or something that
they were trying to promote it's not
like they wanted followers where are we
going to go from Oliver's for followers
where we go from here
what was the planet so let's say you get
1 million views on that YouTube then
what then what the [ __ ] was the plan did
anyone ask that
you just have to keep doing stupid [ __ ]
doesn't say I guess and you become like
the people who do the stupid [ __ ] I've
seen that whole jackass yeah
you're not Steve oh no you're not Johnny
Knoxville we've seen how that end when
I'm sketching that it's just a bomber
man but also where's your family and
friends
I mean Pedro don't anymore Sunday today
it me and Pedro are gonna go shoot this
video I'm gonna shoot him in the chest
of this book no one was like I feel like
it's a bad idea girl I think their aunt
knew about it beforehand to it she's
like I don't think it's a good idea
so I don't know what's going on with
their family and what kind of area this
place is but um there's a weird one what
town is ascent it's in Minnesota keep
going alright next one I'm sure you guys
have seen this by now no I have a
Kurdish woman sniper took a shot and
then like a second later another sniper
on the other side almost hit her head
you could see the blossom I'll show you
the video real quick
Kershner bird giggles when I sister Oh
Sean arrow he misses her and then her
reaction is just laughing holy [ __ ] that
was close yeah damn that's super
gangster god that's thing that she's on
the bed looking it's night I was gonna
say that yeah the women's forces there
they look pretty good I saw the pictures
really I should ypj or some like that
have you heard of that not have not but
I will look into it
all I'm saying is look into it um wow
that's pretty dope yeah I'm right in
time for our our Wonder Woman women
empowerment movement that's going on
right now women are badasses like this
Kurdish sniper like a Wonder Woman
Wonder Woman so hot so real I know she's
all alien Israeli did she was into the
soldier she spent two years in the
military sometimes real to 9 p.m. would
you say that she trained people in like
Krav Maga really yeah yes she is a
attractive woman this is hilarious what
a little badass god the sniper was
straight up
I mean barely miss man she can't give a
[ __ ] and see that blast how it goes
outwards people are saying it's possibly
fake and then this guy drew a diagram
where she's here enemy that shot was
here
why the [ __ ] would it be fake what is
wrong with the world how do you like new
folks trying to get famous bro don't you
favorites man yeah that's what she's
doing so she's gonna allow someone to
shoot a bullet that close to her head so
she can post it while she's killing
[ __ ] I said she needs the same guys
David sometimes society discipline what
else you got you you're not gonna like
this next one it fits another downer I'm
repaired it's a downer but not in that
way so can you smoke some more of those
beers take some more kratom you're
clearly in pain as you looking at these
Curtis for reals
alright so fake old bacteria which is
basically fecal bacteria it was found in
Costa it's a coffee burn our coffee
branch and Starbucks and cafe Nero and
[ __ ] coffee
this is friggin [ __ ] coffee so they
found it in seven out of 10 in Kostka
acosta and then three out of ten samples
in Starbucks but this is in the I think
UK this coffee tastes like [ __ ] yeah
it's a dark roast a bitter [ __ ] um uh
this is legit right BBC legit I mean
wouldn't wouldn't a coffee when it gets
hot wouldn't it just doesn't feel I
don't know it anyway Starbucks said it's
now conduct its own investigation
enjoy that whoever put this out
Starbucks comes with a he yeah they got
money um do some research you better not
be lying Starbucks will roast yo ass
literally could do douche um I listen I
love coffee so much if you told me every
morning you're sipping a little [ __ ] I
would not care I feel like the hot water
kills any bacteria it was so hot
I've watched porn I mean obviously you
can take a little [ __ ] in the mouth I
mean I've seen I've seen some scab paid
very off and Haiti they live on keep my
looking I hold a session video [ __ ] my
cappuccino feels alive at yeah we're
good
I came in the other day and I saw my
girl got in a spread
so and I was like did I send this to the
house why is an espresso here I don't
like those things Matthew I'm old school
I do the French press I do of
traditional man's coffee might not fit
of almond milk here and then little
emulsified MCT perhaps always I never
[ __ ] with the Nespresso Man tastes
funky to me it tastes it doesn't taste
real there's some weird kind of instant
coffee feel to me yeah
the only instant coffee like there's
this brand called forested mag sig Matic
they make like a mushroom coffee it's
pretty dope it's like really uh it's
like cordyceps and some other mushrooms
mixed with coffee and it's instant
sounds kind of nice it's kind of nice
man you get to kind of you get the
benefits of all these medicinal
nutritional mushrooms with the coffee in
it and it's on the go like a little
packet it's good I'm not messing that
yeah are they really expensive huh it's
not too bad yeah it's not it's not crazy
I crazy we're looking into him for the
keto box Sun dome does yeah the nurse
rush stuff incident how about here's a
kernel memory last chin how about George
Clooney I've heard about this now and we
cuz there's a connection so I bring it
up George Clooney is friend would always
go to one spot in Mexico and they would
have there's this amazing tequila there
and they tried get it back to the states
because they loved sipping this tequila
and they tried getting so much of it
back him this friend who were both
richest [ __ ] they just for their own
private use I think the governor was
like man we're going to tax you this
much it was like a time he's like let's
just [ __ ] buy it Bala and sell it so
we can have for ourselves well they did
that and then they started to sell del
Sur and they just sold it for I think
two billion dollars but it all started
with them loving his sipping tequila
tried to get a mass amount of it just
like for him and his boys to party back
to their houses and the government's
like nope we're gonna touch that it was
a Bob Pitman that went in that with him
I think so Bob Pitman and Clooney yeah
who's awesome ego he'll around two or
three billion dollars too good tequila -
and they just cash you 300 us that's
right and I'll start from yeah we like
this trend let's get [ __ ] little bit
back to imagine how many times we've all
done that same thing like been in a
place and like oh wow this this
tequila's really good her this whiskey's
really good okay then let's go out yeah
big next time get more
you know George Turner is like and then
his friend was it had the ideas like man
we should just [ __ ] make the right
connection to this search cell it's so
good yeah and then you know the the
[ __ ] up thing is that amount of money
to them doesn't matter at all
oh no that's how that callin down hello
yo this is George
two billion thoughts on splitter with
him so one good
alright cool have a good day yo that
honey that's how that called goes down
with you George Clooney for me it died
me are you kidding me ah man it's been
nuts oh man I'm calling Ludacris right
up Sean he's [ __ ] DJ hannam-dong me
everybody yeah Luda the [ __ ] you're
downy man [ __ ] him
yeah a dozen show but anyway the guy who
manufacture that deal to do got the sell
thing guy doing the other stuff
nice hell yeah what else she had
students alright so for the fourth time
in a month a great white shark was
washed onshore in South Africa and the
only thing I do this thing is their
liver and it's apparently like surgical
precision that it's missing and they
found out that it's pods of orcas just
going after the liver because it's super
nutrient rich holy [ __ ] orcas are
gangsters i watch something on Shark
Week where the orcas were out hunting
the hunting the great whites and
actually got some footage of that orcas
are like an on another level either like
muster than they're like smart is us
it's like [ __ ] deadly and like a
great life life it's just kill them this
[ __ ] out watch me eat just his liver
damn how ganks are [ __ ] that's a
place concept it's such a weird pretty
animal I mean the exact precision with
which the white and the black like but
this is my favorite animal [ __ ]
SeaWorld if SeaWorld in didn't mark it
as Shamu I don't know if I'm like either
cute not cute but beautiful freezer
because like hot what other animal has
the two-tone paint job like straight
white and straight black a point like
like they for like bandits like they
tape yeah but it's still like it's still
kind of rough and maybe that's cuz they
have fur like it's like ruh
I got this like this is like they like
tape like a car yeah laughing it [ __ ]
paint job on that thing bring out bring
under the other coober aggressive like
look at that that is pretty dope I see I
don't look at that thing go god that's
English like to me like holy [ __ ] like
you do Shamu [ __ ] up for everyone then
once we found out they're like beating
the [ __ ] out of it so dude here that's
for us and then they get all PTSD and
yeah grab your foot and try and drown
you like ya know the wild animal those
things are not you ever seen them when
they got the seals and they [ __ ] flip
the seal in the air just playing catch
with them this gross you're trying to
give them sea teeth and eat them yeah
they flip them tops [ __ ] is happening
they're fake oh hell yeah it's fake it's
a orcas are gnarly animal man and you
see that picture with those kids staring
at the old chairman shadow chairman I
think it passed away now but when their
fins are like that that means they're
basically dying yeah like they're on a
door [ __ ] up
yeah yeah that um that documentary that
came out and I was like fish like fish
oh that came out I kind of sales like
yeah like I don't even think you just
shut it down when that movie comes out
like yeah we have fun we're rich and now
goodbye everybody they were like hey
just so you know we don't even [ __ ] with
the orcas anymore man we still have
stingrays and that's what they're doing
out there marketing everything but
general as well they should I mean that
just that just killed the party that
just shows I shot down you know game
over for that my question for every one
of those what'd you think was happening
yeah we were just going from less like
greater and greater levels of barbarism
to less like people look all the world
so [ __ ] up like yeah kinda but that's
been getting better like it wasn't so
long ago that Mike mental patients were
getting shock therapy and lobotomies
yeah I'm like that agree then there is
all of the horrible things that we were
doing people like it's getting better
it's still not fixed yet yeah we'll look
back at some of the things we do now
like someone who's addicted to drugs we
throw them in a cage in jail because
they're addicted to drugs themselves
well they need they need to get help not
punishment I'm sorry I believe this and
yes
why are we doing all talking about this
with Brian when we're in New York I'll
sit down with his friends over a
delicious meal and we're talking about
you know it's friend who has this cancer
and I'm like chemotherapy and he just
don't have time to do it like I can live
long enough to like it literally does
not matter but we're talking we're you
know we're gonna look back and they're
gonna laugh at chemotherapy doing it it
makes you so sick and so harsh on the
body and check this out about
chemotherapy this is the fact not a lot
of people know the original chemotherapy
was developed when accidentally in World
War two we exploded a bunch of mustard
gas that we were stockpiling and and it
got a bunch of our own troops sick like
a bunch of our own troops got exposed to
mustard gas which they used in World War
one which was [ __ ] horrible and it
was not supposed to have it so they like
rushed in this like clandestine medical
team and they kind of took a look at it
and what they found is is that the
people who had had been exposed to the
mustard gas their lymph cells stop
dividing and that's the exact place
where in lymphoma which is a really
deadly type of camp organ lymphoma
the lymph cells in the lymph glands
start feverishly dividing and that's
what creates the lymphoma so the doctors
are like huh
mustard gas can actually reduce the
activity of lymph cells let's try it on
cancer patient
the very first chemotherapy was actually
mustard gas from the accidental exposure
of chemical warfare like that
it's literally 10 - the chemical warfare
for your body like my shot to Uncle
Pat's pathway he had a cancer in his
throat and mouth and he went through
chemo killed all his taste buds he lost
all his teeth and then they thought he
was good at remiss and came back and
he's like oh my god I'd rather diving
don't feel again that's when he actually
passed away like that we gotta do more
chemo he's like nope not doing it man I
can't taste food I'm not myself I'm
withering away like it's the worst thing
I've ever been through
yeah that's when he's like objects ever
and jellies anybody who's interested
there's a book called tripping over the
truth the metabolic theory of cancer I
recently read it it totally changed my
perspective on cancer and it's based on
this dr. Otto Warburg who understood
that the one unifying factor of all
cancer cells is that they ferment oxygen
I mean they ferment sugar
a form of cellular respiration instead
of the normal mitochondrial process and
he identified that super early on but
it's kind of just been like this random
fact that people have been looking at
but now treatments are coming out where
they're looking at doing a restricted
ketogenic diet which really starves the
body of all the sugar yeah and then
rehabilitative like metabolic processes
like hyperbaric oxygen and the treatment
of cancer and showing like really
promising results and with that so
definitely check that book out if
anybody if you're affected anybody
defective I have a book review up Aubry
Marcus Comstock cancer just check the
book review really [ __ ] interesting
going into like that's where I got the
story about chemotherapy tells the whole
story of cancer and shows some real hope
and promise for what radical diet
intervention can do just basically
starving the cells of the sugar and
rehabilitating them shifting that idea
from this war on cancer war or war to
saying oh these cells are sick you know
they're not the mitochondria aren't
functioning properly let's rehabilitate
these cells get them back working
instead of just we got to destroy this
thing yeah you know you know uh chemo
radiation kill everything what survives
what survives will live you know just a
whole different shift on it and
obviously more data and research needs
to come out but this is a scientific
book this is not again theory it's not
precise this is based on that unreal
data so anybody I highly encourage it's
not too advanced what's it called
tripping over the truth to metabolic
theory of cancer author's name is
Kristofferson with a sketch in you guys
want to talk about that president tweet
from today oh good so on Morning Joe he
has a co-host and I guess they're
talking crap on on Trump and then Trump
tweeted this about the co-hosts her name
is Mika and then he's making fun of her
for having like plastic surgery so he
put I heard poorly rated at morning
underscore Joe speaks badly of me
don't watch anymore all right then how
come
then how come low IQ crazy Mike along
with psycho Joe came to Marla go three
nights in a row around New Year's Eve
and insisted on joining me she was
bleeding badly from a facelift
I said no I did to me what whatever
qualms whatever issues you have with
these people
that's our the leader of the free that
is the most powerful man in the world
tweets he's so petty he tweets out this
[ __ ] I've never heard of this morning
show a [ __ ] you do here's my
address 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue it so
gets up you make a pilot figures Secret
Service you can find me in the Oval
Office my body you know where I'm at I
would love that you with your fake-ass
profile living in your mom's babies goes
off it goes like Dana White's move holy
God I supposed to cuddle but she leave a
number that's the front desk you I'll be
in the [ __ ] Oval Office you can
get it too
yeah that's really what we would prefer
that in there it's just so it's just so
a petty man yeah I don't you have way
bigger why isn't a [ __ ] are you even
addressing this stuff there's a million
problems you got all the million
fighters you got to put out why are you
even in playing this game why is you why
you're shown on the radar it's you know
like like it this this morning Joe has
got to be stoked
yeah great I'm not her the guy great
press yeah great
now everybody who hates Trump is gonna
be listed in the morning general you can
build a career that's a career building
tweet good job Obama never [ __ ] what
Obama's like let what I write tweet
someone a morning show a talk [ __ ] why
would I do that
or you talking [ __ ] to Arnold
Schwarzenegger like Congrats on your
ratings are they suck all right bro year
the president why are we talking like
are you still need to feel bigger and
tougher and stronger like one you want
man here's the President of the United
States you won
why are you worried about the ratings on
[ __ ] whatever [ __ ] NBC show that
was god it's just disappointing range
times
strange strange times so I don't like
celebrities as your president what else
you get to you want one enemy one yes do
101 so Dana says that Connor told him
straight up that after the may with a
fight he wants to fight kebede in Russia
and dannegan skinny
goddamn I don't blame the VAT for in
million my face ago maybe um so he's
saying that Connor wants Russia r1
spikes could be even Moscow I don't buy
it man what I think is going on here and
it's a great play by Dana you know this
reason why he's one if not the greatest
promoter in the world especially best of
all time mixed martial arts but this he
says stuff like this but I think what's
going on is this kind of forces Conor
now to fight because what you're really
doing is putting pressure you putting
the ball in Conners corner and going
remember right you said Russia khabib
like that's right Sutton Connor didn't
expect was going to get out maybe he
mentioned it I'm sure Connors fully
devote he's just in this for mayweather
fight he has his hands full obviously in
this fight he's a huge underdog I doubt
he's gonna know let's do could be brush
after this I just it to me it's a
business move it's David going yep yeah
if you walk away you're this big [ __ ]
now you look the pressures on you gotta
fight to be in Moscow
well I think it's also you know you're
going to want to capitalize on this
exposure is a good chance Conor loses
this fight yeah I mean there's some
chance that he can do some [ __ ] to yeah
I think we've talked about that as well
but it's a good chance he loses the
bonding man more likely than not he
dances the fight bios's but if you have
this story running concurrently then
while the whole world is watching you
have this compelling thing he's going in
deep into enemy territory indica Beebe's
country like Napoleon tried to conquer
Russia and couldn't but can Conor yeah
come in and so you have this storyline
to pivot to even if he gets his ass
kicked it's like yeah well it was boxing
of course would you expect but now he's
back to MMA going into Russia
it saves the UFC's ass yeah it's a smart
move I think actually both for Conor and
for the UFC like to have something to
pivot off of already rather than what's
Conor going to do now you answer that
question immediately and get people
excited for the next thing based upon
this thing so I good again and you know
I'd like I was the very first media
member or whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call me Satanas next fight against Floyd
Mayweather I said that the day after you
five it's documented I did on J and
dance I need my neighborhood now y'all
these dick riders jumping on trying to
jump on them bags accessing now that's
happening I don't think that's the next
move for Connor I don't see that I do
not see why he'd fight an unknown named
I and khabib who's insanely dangerous I
get he's a drawn Russia but over here is
he ain't [ __ ] who just miss wait it has
a real issue making 155 so you didn't go
around doing a world press tour
you're the biggest drawn combat sports
history and your wrists all that hoping
this guy makes the delay and you just
miss wait for a huge interim title shot
get the [ __ ] out of here you know they
give me his the move is Nate Diaz three
trilogy that's your money fighting
that's the again it's a tough fight it's
a safer fight than could beam he's a
everyone knows Nate Diaz everyone see
that trilogy it's the B's paper you knew
see history so it's either
he fights Floyd rise up in the sunset
with his hundred million or he comes
back for one more only one more and he
fights Nate Diaz for the rubber trilogy
but cab even Russia ain't happening Dana
I know you're pushing I know he said he
wants that but they're gonna sit down
and go let's just look at the numbers
let's get the money here well trilogy
with Nate who we beat before and he's
beat us it's one one that's gonna be a
way bigger draw than fighting khabib
that no one knows I hate to tell you we
know them because we like MMA you talk
to any casual fans like who they don't
know that's not the play it's just not
to play dead that's not gonna happen it
is sexy though going to Russia
fighting Cabiria it is Oreskes know very
exactly yeah I think I think about the
world while you put it on the pressure
planet to be his the last fight he
making 155 his liver shut down yeah he
almost died he could get rushed to a
hospital that's how tough it is for Nick
55 so you're gonna go on a world tour
and promote this fight when I'm doing
misses wait what do you do Tony
waiting in the wings crazy right yeah
yeah you know you're not gonna see it
man he's too much of liabilities and I'm
big in the flame
you think khabib is probably Connors
worst matchup or I don't think he's a
but I don't know I don't think I think
is
out this matchup I don't think it's his
worst matchup there's you know there's
not a lot of there's not a lot of
terrible matchups for Connor on the feet
Connors you know light years ahead of
them grappling is give me a tough thing
for Connor you know but tell me
Ferguson's tough match for him you're
never again seen fight could be never
seen fight Tony you're gonna see a
trilogy with Nate Diaz ESCA be gone
fourth fifth round I don't think he's
been a fifth round her not sure ah -
this fight with dos Anjos was in a five
rounder is I don't think he think he's
ever been a main event Michael Johnson
and in three nope sure has every yeah
that's interesting you know one thing
watching him watching Conor deal with
Chad Mendes is like just with just
withstanding that yes in his ear talking
the whole time you're not really hurting
me I mean could be he's a granted a
different monster but they're similar in
their yeah explosive dick downs or
strength yeah and I think that would be
the that would be Connors way to weather
that storm is just just keep pouring
like the effort intensity get taken down
for the first few rounds could be he
gets a little more tired stuff that
first shot doubts his mind and you know
round for whatever and then the left
comes hunting and and here's the other
thing name the best striker to Biebs
beat go woody got Jim able to heal yeah
name the world-class striker he's beat
up there actually Michael Johnson only
the best earn a real striker like allow
actual knockout hours [ __ ] savant
it's staying up go dude cat Zeke Azam
body on yeah yeah for sure hey gentlemen
yeah yeah none that guy's a killer some
think of it is almost as good as shamil
Abdullah Rimet enough yeah it God dog
his shot you know dr7 wind I'm a high
all they need those spell and be honest
not be his verse 17 wins goddamn shamil
about the Lamar off to spell that kids
are my god so much I get a verb
well thinking in the adjectives you'd
Scrabble with the Scrabble and all night
they call my play Scrabble Russia this
is your table I saw three nice things I
have no letters like I did switch and
everything's wise disease and I goddamn
it I gotta tell like why I got the are
again use it I needed more Bligh's and V
I can't spell anything yeah looking game
sucks yeah I think I saw Dana said that
it's a good business move by him that
makes no sense on Connors and all in
remember Connors does the eight Connors
such a big star especially after no
matter what happens is fully made with a
fight unless he hit smirked in like 30
seconds which isn't gonna happen but
he's gonna be such the a side he's bit
his brand for the very first time ever
in combat sports switching you see he's
bigger than the USC and they never
thought this was gonna happen you're
never gonna see again because the new
contracts now that he set these trends
the contracts and tie these guys up so
we can't get bigger than UFC but Connor
he broke that ceiling they didn't think
about these lawyers from Harvard Yale
they didn't think this was possible yeah
the levered they couldn't imagine like
lad no way his leverage will trump a
contract at any point like if you get
leveraged genuine leverage then you have
power and that's what Connor did and but
Connor is that once-in-a-generation
[ __ ] yep you know like truly
once in the dinner I think it's
interesting because you know I am
O'Connor fan I do too think Connor and
you know I do this thing with Showtime
I'm doing all this stuff and be like god
you're Connor Dick Rider and to me I
find answering because um you people are
fans of Mike Tyson the fans of Bruce Lee
he's in that genre man but he's just
present right now so we take uh we go
your dick rider but you have a Mike
Tyson sure Tommy how my dick rider you
have a Mike Tyson Bruce Lee Pierre
sweats on you have a goddamn Michael
Jordan Jersey now we're gonna look bass
in 30 years and doing like how about
comma Gregor man totally and then you're
gonna see shirts and he's there's gonna
be this legacy but people don't stop and
smell the roses as it's happening as
you're witnessing history and greatness
they don't stop and smell the roses they
wait till these guys die
go back watch Muhammad Lissa tapes you
[ __ ] idiot
if you would have just paid attention
he's always been appeased you didn't
spend time or this triple G Canelo oh
your dick right on Canelo
he's greatness man he's one of these
legends you're talking about twenty
years but you're so into everything and
you know you're not realizing what's
going on right now with LeBron James or
Russell Westbrook or Kevin Durant you're
witnessing legends history that people
talk about for years and years to come
but you're so caught up in all this
there's all this stimulation your dick
Ryder no [ __ ]
I appreciate greatness these guys are
legends for a reason that is it is the
most beautiful thing that there is a
certain level of greatness that is just
it's intangible right you just feel it
coming off someone in certain moments
and some people can just touch it you
know like when tjb Tannen Burrell like
you felt that you felt that for that
fight for that moment and you know but
Connor somehow manages to bring that
every [ __ ] time you know and like
when you see that you got to just
appreciate and that's the huge joy
that's a huge x fact in this boxing
that's what all these mainstream media
they they what they they haven't put in
the work and they didn't witness
firsthand and they didn't they weren't
there to see it in person that they
weren't there to watch it live on
pay-per-view at UFC 204 all these huge
these huge taxis past they haven't seen
that just go through the record okay TKO
KO decision okay and he's fighting this
boxer but they don't realize and I can't
I don't know how you're gonna bobble it
I don't know what adjectives you want to
put on how you can describe it he has
that it factor and they go yeah I know
but Brock Lesnar had that Rhonda had
that no no no no I [ __ ] get that for
it has that expected he doesn't have the
neck sector for you Sam ASP he's a
technician counter punchers when the
greatest of all time not get hit I get
that I'm telling you he has something
that we have not seen I've never I've
been around so many athletes man well my
best friends Tim Tebow I'm telling you
there's a difference between these guys
in Conor McGregor I don't know what the
[ __ ] it is I do I could not tell you I
don't know
it's something going on upstairs with
the big man I don't know if this dublin
[ __ ] special sauce
maybe there's a shitload of Lucky Charms
I'm not sure I had a ton of Lucky Charms
as a kid and I don't have it but he has
something and I am willing to bet on
that because Mayweather does not and
that's what these old school dinosaurs
cannot they can't comprehend those being
open-minded they just can't get it ah
but he did he doesn't have Olympic medal
in boxing I get all that man I get that
but I get your argument but how can you
quantify what this guy has done in four
years
yeah he may not have all those
credentials but he might be able to bend
space-time yeah I like me a [ __ ] bend
five guys I don't know what I don't know
is I've seen some weird [ __ ] I don't
know what is when I'm laughing but in
just as a businessman he's outsmarted
the UFC you know how hard that is to do
none of us could do it he's done it it's
[ __ ] nuts and you cannot take that
away for you can't take that for granted
it's nuts man the like the old you know
kind of the Toltec masters who
considered themselves something of
magicians right they talk about actual
magic isn't spells and [ __ ] like [ __ ]
where the wizard Hatton's
leaves it's about setting your intent
and having reality match your intent
like they believe that if they set their
intent with their beliefs strong enough
they could bend the world you there
believe it can happen to make it happen
and that's something you see over and
over again with champions their belief
bends reality too you see them Merle
tano has in his gym is a picture of him
knocking out phileo that's a huge
painting there's all that so cocky
that's so I'm like know what he's doing
he's walking and visualizing that every
day because he first it starts with
visualization and then you make it
happen comes reality but that vision has
to start somewhere
yeah and it's going to be and that's
just in this somatic thing that split
second where you're even sub cerebral
processing where you just throw that
counter exactly at the right time it's
not like it's not actual magic it's just
it bends yourself to be in a position to
act the way that you need I did this
thing with Mara Ronaldo who's
mastermind in boxing he does all the
Showtime he does
Bellator now he did pride four years
guess on who he is he's a master went
into combat sports and we shot this
thing for Showtime the thing comes out
next week and he looks mean Ines Brennan
you actually believe Conor McGregor
believes he's going to win this fight
and I went if you even have to ask that
you do not know who you're dealing with
man cuz Conor McGregor out of anyone the
world not only does he think he's going
to win deep down in every cell in his
body he thinks he's gonna knock him out
miss this isn't me to cut a promo for
them this isn't I truly believe that
100% deep down in his heart he was not
taking this fight just for the money he
set on money I'll see not this much
money
I'll see money is intangible there but
in his heart of heart in his entire camp
they believe he's going to knock him out
and that is in the fight game that is so
meaningful man especially when you have
the size the quickness the mindset the
IQ and you put all that together he's
the bigger guy and then you have a 40
year old Mike I got some blue in the
face man you know what do you like the
other hot the other factor to the other
factor too is like has Floyd Mayweather
ever gone and looked right in the eye of
a man who was 100% certain that they
were right like that is something that
shakes you a little bit like wait you're
a hundred percent for today whether yeah
and Flynn comes like I know he's like I
know and I'm a hundred percent sure yeah
and then that you then you leave
thinking this dude's [ __ ] crazy or
maybe he knows something that I don't
and me and maybe that won't happen maybe
Floyd's immune to it and he's too good
for that because I mean maybe they will
maybe maybe that'll shake him for like
goddamn maybe he does know something and
that little doubt will start to [ __ ]
with him you know a lot of [ __ ] could
happen here dude that I saw so everybody
tags me all the Floyd Connor stuff down
there's a thing on the at debts but I
actually love debts when Shantanu
Deadspin and they posted a video
Floyd hit in the Dublin bag first lost
the biggest Dublin bag I've ever seen
but he send this Dublin bad
oh [ __ ] Connors in trouble it's just in
like warming up on the mic god damn it
and they go shops gonna let better jobs
gonna love this ed line I'm like what
sucks is all the people I guess just in
everyone and I mean just you know
everyone's just trying to capitalize on
this huge fight of our lifetime it's the
biggest fight of our lives you have a
financial prediction for sales I'm not
don't really follow that for review so
yeah it's gonna it's going to beat
Pacquiao Mayweather yeah I will say that
biggest the biggest of all time are you
small-time yeah
these fight of all time these sign of a
lifetime beautiful ain't you coming up
soon I just hope they make it through I
could be so bummed if someone got hurt
or some [ __ ] oh my oh [ __ ] yeah
everybody will sounds like Flamel yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
[ __ ] sakes how crazy and I'm gonna
announce any day now how crazy is it I'm
doing a show in Dublin the bank on that
card good it'll stop these [ __ ] nuts
and hans and you're on the right side of
that as far as your opinion that's
imatinib lot of dublin to [ __ ] it was a
team money Mayweather sir to break down
Connor for IRA do I RA just kick each
it's [ __ ] crazy
how we got started is edit for Christian
that's pretty much it [ __ ] brilliant
man yeah we don't need a Brian counts
dropping off stage because I'll be
Marcus dropped a boatload of no I'm
[ __ ] but everything man so you get
your book your deadlines win so
deadlines coming up this summer I had to
push it once so we'll see because it's
just I want to make sure this thing is
the best I can possibly do so the books
called own the day that will be out
sometime in spring of 2018 but uh in the
meantime check out the podcast
Aubrey Marcus podcast your podcasts are
kind of kill them agenda podcasts a lot
of people come up to me and talk about
the podcast man thanks brother yeah
Jamie Foxx on you my boy Piven on yeah
yeah a lot of good guess and sometimes
the people you don't expect like under
the radar you know random authors like
Jamie wheel like Gerard Butler found me
because he listened to my podcast
with Jamie wheel what you doing the
droid Butler out here first yeah and
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna go
and we're gonna go deep to we're going
to talk about some [ __ ] he's never
talked about so that'll be fun like how
you get disastrous two hundred yeah man
we are DS different we talked about that
a bit yeah he say out so that was the
progenitor of CrossFit really Jim Jones
raining and you know those guys were
pushing hard but they were also kind of
knuckleheads too like when you need more
clothes do you mean tutorial cycles yeah
yeah like lotta actors getting injured
and it was it was interesting to hear
the story of like of the training and
how it all how it all went generally he
needs to tell that hot can it was I was
like it was [ __ ] really really
fascinating I think it'd be faster and
talked about that talked about you know
is he's had issues with alcoholism and
you know in Hollywood and this huge
movie stars and he could falls from
grace and he's kind of back and 300 in
that body and just there's a million
things tucked him about yeah he was
talking about how like people who go
take he'll go to take his shirt off with
some lady just mad at somebody and
they'll be like expecting 300 bodies
like listen oh yeah movie a little bit
ahead lane is that you're not going to
get that he can't have a public dance
[ __ ] yeah
what the [ __ ] Japanese I get you know
eight 300 pies that's what the [ __ ]
happened that's exactly what happened
yeah I bet every good night we dying
that Wendy who's mad yeah two girls like
this is terrible a lot of its Photoshop
there's air spray you know this it's the
movie so they probably forgotten things
you know he's not shredded spectacular
24/7 a lot of people think I do like you
see people on men's health and men's
fitness
they think they're walking around like
that it's like nothing odd I'd like a
[ __ ] for that exact shoot man
that's not realistic know how we got
there but uh yeah your podcast is
killing it man thanks brother yeah and
for people interested in the psychedelic
stuff I'm dropping I did seven podcasts
that I recorded at the psychedelic
science with all the head chief
scientist Jesus of these different
organizations so look for that that's
going to drop in August they're all
going to drop as a batch
we're going to put some content around
and really try to get the message out -
that's cool man that Marcus before I get
you out is the last time I asked you to
do that we're going to lunch other so
I'm sure be talking your ear off uh what
what's the next thing for on it right
you know I'm saying like you guys are
killing it you get the nootropics the
alpha brain troop tech all that stuff
you got the the gym you know you get the
Academy
you got Dwayne like muy Thai bank I you
got friggin Eddie Bravo ten Flintridge
it's ooh yeah all that like what's next
you know I'm saying like what do you
guys know from here it's food man I
think food is going to be a big play and
we've been talking about that and we'll
you know I'm sure talk more about that
it gets a little closer but finding ways
I mean we have the supplements to
training a lot of that but the actual
food the dietary part so more
information I think the book is going to
help with a lot of that really putting
out solid science-based information
about what we should eat what we
shouldn't which is more important let's
be honest and supplements retain its the
real foundation of it right so having
that information really leveling up that
information put out a great article
about coconut oil if you check out the
Anand Academy there's some [ __ ] that
came out about coconut oils all nonsense
yeah read the article we put I did a
podcast about it too you know basically
like I don't even want to get into just
check it out it'll show the actual truth
about saturated fats in coconut oil
again people unwilling to change their
mind defending old positions defending
old ideas that have been completely
debunked so information mix with some
cool key products that we can get people
like expose them to what's possible
exposing with stuff that doesn't feel
like a sacrifice yeah
like when they have it I know one of the
products we love is like those cave
shakes hell yeah it tastes like a great
[ __ ] milkshake that you love yeah and
it's so good for you you know and
there's so many things like that in food
that we just want to expose people to
give them the information give them some
delicious [ __ ] that they can like and
then they'll have the supplements and
the training and then the inspiration
you know more of that constantly putting
out videos to get people fired up like
that olestra direction god say yeah man
let's it's [ __ ] have fun yeah let's
have fun let's be the best we can be I
can enjoy it
I did get my whole point boom app Audrey
Marcus on Instagram Twitter yes sir
boom boom thanks coming in brother yeah
man recording so interesting
always a pile of it man alright guys
thanks for tuning in this is the fighter
and the chosen one our remarks we're out
reef